instead of asking why is it being held
there
first ask
why not
unless we are talking about a kind of
entitlement
that only some of us on this globe
deserve
to enjoy
it's about keeping some people
in their place but
that kind of attitude
should have been left far behind
in history
by now
that is not to say that athletes
do not have a right to object to what
personally affects them and their
communities
they certainly do
politics in sports
reflects the problems
that Society
faces
when funds throw
bananas at African
football players
or turned a female referee
that is because of a negative social
environment
that feeds those wrong behaviors
so we need to act together
to ensure that the game is inclusive
and respectful of everyone
ladies and gentlemen once again I
welcome you to Kigali and Hope
that you will keep coming back
to visit us you will be very welcome
I wish you a very productive meeting
and thank you for your kind attention
[Applause]
thank you very much president kagame
for your inspiring
words
so now we can move on to agenda item two
the roll call and the Declaration that
the Congress has been convened and
composed in compliance with the statutes
and for this
I hand over the floor to Secretary
General please
thank you Mr President
let's indeed start with the roll code
Afghanistan present
Albania present
Algeria present
American Samoa present
Andorra present
Angola present
Angelia presence
Antigua and Barbuda present
Argentina present
Armenia present
Aruba present
Australia presence
Austria presence
Azerbaijan presence
the Bahamas presence
Bahrain present
Bangladesh present
Barbados present
Belarus presence
Belgium present
Belize present
Benin present
Bermuda presence
Bhutan present
Bolivia present
present
Botswana presence
Brazil present
British Virgin Islands present
Brunei darussalam present
Bulgaria present
Burkina Faso present
Burundi presence
present
Cambodia present
Cameroon present
Canada present
Cayman Islands present
Republic of central Africa presence
child presence
Chile presence
people Republic of China are present
Chinese Taipei present
Colombia present
comoros presence
Congo present
Dr Congo present
cook Island present
Costa Rica present
foreign
Cuba present
presence
Cyprus present
present
Denmark present
Djibouti present
Dominica present
Dominican Republic present
Ecuador present
Egypt presence
El Salvador present
England presence
a present
Eritrea present
Estonia present
swatini present
Ethiopia present
far away Islands present
Fiji present
Finland present
France presence
Gabon present
The Gambia present
Georgia present
Germany present
Ghana present
Gibraltar present
Greece present
Granada present
Guam present
Guatemala present
Guinea present
presence
Guyana present
Haiti present
Honduras present
Hong Kong present
Hungary present
Islam presence
India present
Indonesia presence
Islamic Republic of Iran present
Iraq present
Republic of Ireland presence
Israel present
Italy present
Jamaica present
Japan present
Jordan present
Kazakhstan present
present
Democratic people Republic of Korea
absence
Korea Republic present
Kosovo present
Kuwait present
guilty's Republic present
law was present
that we are present
Lebanon present
Lesotho present
Liberia present
Libya present
ation style presence
Lithuania present
Luxembourg presence
presence
Madagascar present
Malawi present
Malaysia present
Maldives present
Mali presence
Malta present
Islamic Republic of Mauritania present
Mauritius present
Mexico present
Moldova present
Mongolia present
Montenegro presents
Montserrat absence
Morocco present
Mozambique present
Myanmar present
in Namibia present
Nepal present
New Zealand oh sorry Netherlands present
New Caledonia presence
New Zealand presence
Nicaragua presence
Niger presence
Nigeria present
North Macedonia present
Northern Island present
Norway present
Oman present
Pakistan present
Palestine present
Panama present
Papua New Guinea present
Paraguay present
Peru present
Philippines present
for land present
Portugal present
Puerto Rico present
Qatar present
Romania presence
Russian Federation present
Rwanda presence
Samoa present
San Marino presence
and Principe present
Saudi Arabia present
Scotland present
Senegal present
Serbia present
Seychelles present
Sierra Leone present
Singapore president
Slovenia presence
Salomon Islands present
Somalia present
South Africa presence
South Sudan president
Spain present
Sri Lanka
presence
some kids and neighbors present
Saint Lucia present
Saint Vincent and the gradient presence
Sudan present
Suriname present
Sweden present
Switzerland present
Syria present
Tahiti present
Tajikistan present
Tanzania present
Thailand presence
presence
Togo present
Tonga present
Trinidad and Tobago present
Tunisia present
turkey presence
Turkmenistan presence
Turk and Caicos Islands present
Uganda presence
Ukraine present
United Arab Emirates present
Uruguay present
USA present
U.S Virgin Islands present
Uzbekistan present
Vanuatu present
Venezuela present
Vietnam present so before we move on
with the Congress
we would like to
for a moment and remember the members of
the football team who have left us in
the last year
a look at this video please
[Music]
foreign
thank you very much and they obviously
remain all in our hearts and especially
person that left us and has only touched
the hearts of all of us
thanks to his incredible human and
footballing skills before we do events I
would like you to watch this video as
well
the king Pele
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
thank you
possibility
as this is important
position
thank you I would like to ask you to
stand up please and have a minute of
Silent prayer thank you
thank you thank you
foreign
and thank you again to Rwanda for having
named one of its stadiums after the king
Pele
so we can move on to the agenda agenda
item three appointment of scrutinies and
members
to check the minutes
um
Padma
yes Mr President we are going to vote
for the appointment of the three
scrutiniors to examine the function of
the electronic voting system and sign
the record of the vote
appointment of the AIDS scrutinia to
count the voting by show of hand an
appointment of five nations to check the
minutes
the following three members Association
have been proposed
to uh examine the functioning of the
electronic voting system and sign the
record of the vote Vanuatu ways and
Zambia
eight member Association have been
proposed
to serve as scrutiner to count the
voting by a show of hands Brazil New
Zealand
Palestine Spain Suriname
Turkmenistan and Uganda
and finally
it is proposed that the following member
Association
check the minutes Papua New Guinea
Sweden Togo United Arab Emirates and
Venezuela we are going to vote until in
Block for the tribatch of super 10 years
so
vote on the approval of the appointment
of the streets cuteness to examine the
functioning of the electronic voting
system and signed the record of the vote
of AIDS continues to count the voting by
show of hand five member Association to
check the minute
if you agree with a proposal
press yes
if you disagree press no and if you have
stayed press abstention the vote is
starting now for 30 seconds and please
remember to submit your vote vote start
[Music]
then second remaining before the rose
thank you
Lord is now close and let's wait for the
result
the president
delegates 108 member Association
eligible to vote
203 have voted in favor of the motion
they will no disagreement
so the Congress has therefore approved
that the following and agree that the
following member Association be
appointed as to 10 years there is
continues to examine the functioning of
the electronic voting system and sign
the record of the vote Vanuatu wins
Zambia
eight scrutineers to count votes by show
of hands Brazil New Zealand Palestine
Spain Suriname Togo Sally and Uganda and
finally five member Association to check
the minutes
apua New Guinea Sweden Tunisia United
Arab Emirates and Venezuela Florida back
to you Mr President
thank you very much and thanks to
everyone for this vote we can move to
agenda item number four an unpleasant
one unfortunately suspension
or expulsion of a member Association
let's start with the situation of that
Zimbabwe Football Association the FIFA
Council suspended the Zimbabwe Football
Association on 24th 2022 with immediate
effect due to third-party interference
in particular the Takeover of the
activities of the Zimbabwe Football
Association by a so-called restructuring
committee appointed by the government
after the latter had suspended the
executive committee and genos which
obviously constitutes a serious
violation of the FIFA statutes
on 31st of March 22 the 72nd FIFA
Congress confirmed already the
suspension of the Zimbabwe Football
Association
but unfortunately since the Zimbabwe
Football Association has not yet
fulfilled direct to lift the suspension
it is recommended by the council that
the Congress once more confirmed the
suspension of the Zimbabwe Football
Association enabling at the same time
the council to lift the suspension as
soon as the pertinent requirements are
met
please yes Mr President
so the vote
is for the suspension of the Zimbabwe
Football Association enabling the
council to lift the suspension once the
personal requirements have been
fulfilled press yes if you agree with
the most no if you disagree and press
abstention if you
abstain and always remember to press
submit button the vote is starting now
and you have 30 seconds
[Music]
thank you
ten more seconds to go
the wood is now closed and let's wait
for the results
the president uh
199 member Association have voted in
favor of the motion for the suspension
of Football Association and one member
Association voted against the motion the
Congress has therefore confirmed the
suspension of the Zimbabwe Football
Association
and effectively reconfirming that they
are not entitled to vote at this
Congress
Lord to exercise any of their membership
rights go back to you Mr President
thank you very much
um the second Association is the
Football Federation of Sri Lanka
also there the Bureau of the FIFA
Council suspended the Football
Federation of Sri Lanka on the 21st of
January 2023 with immediate effect due
to third-party interference in
particular it was the interference of
the ministry of views and sports
[Music]
thank you
Mission from the Electoral roadmap that
was agreed upon by FIFA the Football
Federation of Sri Lanka and the ministry
itself which obviously constitutes a
serious violation of the FIFA statutes
the FIFA Council ratified this decision
of the bureau on the 14th of February
it is therefore recommended by the
council that the Congress
confirm this suspension of the football
federations enabling however again the
council to lift the suspension as soon
as the pertinent requirements have been
fulfilled again for the vote please
thank you Mr President instructional
reads as fellow we are going to vote
on the suspension of the Football
Federation of Sri Lanka enabling the
council to lift the suspension once the
personal requirement have been fulfilled
press yes if you agree no if you
disagree an abstention if you abstain
and the vote is starting now
[Music]
thank you
ten more seconds to go before what is
closed
what is now closed
and let's wait for the results
the president
197 member Association voted for the
suspension of the Football Federation of
Sri Lanka
and meaning that Sri Lanka
will affect is effectively reconfirmed
that it is not entitled to vote at this
Congress nor exercise any of its
membership rights
motion is passed Mr President Flores
back to you
thank you very much
so we can move directly to agenda item
five which is
the approval of the agenda you all
received the agenda of course and I hand
over immediately for the vote Yes a
straightforward vote it's for the
[Music]
the vote is open now
10 seconds ago before the vote is closed
boat is now closed
the large majority almost everybody
voted to approve the agenda of the 73rd
FIFA congress with
206 member Association
approving the proposal and no abstention
and no disagreement the motion is passed
Mr President
thank you very much then we can go to
agenda item six the approval of the
minutes of the agenda
so I just want to remember that remind
you that the minutes of the 72nd
Congress have been checked by the
following member associations Burkina
fazo Honduras Liechtenstein Monserrat
Singapore
I hand over now to the Secretary General
for the vote that's the president
instruction reads as follow approve vote
on approval of the minutes of the
72nd FIFA Congress that took place on
the 31st of March last year press yes
to approve
no
to disagree or abstention to approve and
always press submit button to validate
your vote and the vote is now open for
30 seconds
[Music]
thank you
ten more seconds to go before vote is
closed
vote is now closed and let's wait for
the result
foreign
201 member Association out of
207 now eligible to vote have voted in
favor of the approval of the minutes of
the last year Congress in Doha we
consider the motion passed and the floor
is back to you Mr President for your
address
thank you very much so I will move over
to the lecture for my others thank you
thank you
so dear vice presidents
council members
presidents
delegates
Legends
family friends
often the same
this is a very special address of course
or should be a special address because
it is the address
taking place at an electoral Congress
the first
electoral Congress of FIFA taking place
in Africa
and even if
I'm running an opposed and I would like
to thank you in advance
for all your support
which means a lot to me
I think it is important to highlight
in such a day some of the achievements
of the last four years
and some of the projects of the next
four years
so I hope
you are ready for that
because everything that we did
everything that I did as your president
everything that we did with our team
we try to do it
for all of you
for each and every one of you here
for each and every football fan
out there
because we should always remember one
thing which is that FIFA
is an association of associations of 211
countries from all over the world from
all over the world
211 more than the United Nations
and for FIFA
each and every one
in these countries has exactly the same
duties and exactly the same rights
including the right
to be respected
for what he is for what he does
for what she is for what she does
and we want to unite and we want to
include and we want to make football
truly Global so
I don't like to speak about myself
normally but sometimes maybe you have to
a little bit
because at the end I'm the president and
I have to take some responsibility so
what did I promise you
well I promised you and very few were
believing it
that we would live the best World Cup
ever
and we delivered
we organized the best World Cup ever
we had 5 billion viewers all over the
world
we had 3 million fans in the stadiums
we had teams from five different
continents qualifying for The Knockout
phase
something new in Morocco first African
team
in the semi-final a brook
felicidades Argentina of course
to win
This World Cup
congratulations as well to friends for
being that close to winning the trophy
we had excellent stadiums
perfect infrastructure no incident
zero incidents some were telling me well
maybe it's linked with the fact that
people were not drinking alcohol in and
around the stadiums maybe maybe not
but it was a very peaceful and joyful
World Cup and of course we took on board
as well our responsibility to deal with
human rights
matters and to deal with the legacy of
this worker the first in the Middle East
shukran Qatar
on a
secondly we have promised you that we
would organize
the best
the most beautiful
FIFA Women's World Cup and we did so
in 2019 in France
we created we organized we hosted a
beautiful Woman's World Cup
1.2 billion viewers around the world
[Music]
this environment
led to impressive progress in
globalization
in globalizing women's football and
therefore thank you to France
congratulations for the us as they won
the trophy
it was once again the best
we also promised you all
that
we both strengthened FIFA that we was
strengthening as FIFA with a stable
Association very strong because you
never know what could happen and
when things happen we need to be strong
and we need to be prepared and something
did happen
something very serious
the world stopped because of covet
as a result
solid and strong situation in FIFA we
managed to establish the covet relief
plan
a support plan of 1.5 billion dollars
this FIFA covet relief plan supported so
many of you out there
it supported you to keep football alive
funds youth football women's football
not professional football
but that football that we all
experienced all of us and that's thanks
to the work that we have all carried out
together
that we were going to increase
our revenues
and make FIFA more stable
and more transparent
therefore regaining the trust of
sponsors and broadcasters
to be honest I was not so sure whether
we would achieve that
because we set an ambitious Target at
6.4 billion
US dollars
but we did perform
our revenues have gone up to a record
7.5 billion US dollars more than one
billion more than what was budgeted in a
period which was hit by covet you cannot
do this
if you are not strong
if you are not a strong and solid
organization which is trusted
by everyone
and I would like to remind you as well
that when I arrived in FIFA the FIFA
reserves were around 1 billion US
dollars
today
the FIFA reserves are at almost 4
billion US Dollars which means we have
even more
money that we can inject and invest in
football because the money of FIFA is
your money is the money of football or
football
development
and
you know
I promised you that we would raise all
programs that we will have more
development programs in the world
and we did so
many of you may remember than before
being elected as FIFA presidents each
Federation would receive 250
000 dollars per year
250 000 and now they receive 2 billion
dollar per year
so it's seven times more in seven years
we did multiply the investment
by seven
if a CEO
tells to the stakeholders that the
products were multiplied by seven I
believe that they would keep that CEO
forever
they would love for this story to keep
on going but I'm here for a four-year
cycle only
foreign
but dear friends
it is important
it is important that the governance of
FIFA works
and that is why we promised you
that
we will reinforce FIFA's governance
every single dollar that is being
invested
in the projects in the associations
will undergo an audit an independent
audit
money just doesn't get lost anymore
and that is why
we are so optimistic and positive
that is also why the institutions and
not only the sponsors and the
broadcasters have regained their trust
in FIFA
the Department of Justice For example of
the United Nations of the United States
has given us in the last year
more than 200 and millions back
that
was stolen by corrupt officials of FIFA
and now they have been given back to us
and we were able to reinvest it into
football
concacaf and conanball for example
if institutions didn't trust
especially the American institutions
they wouldn't do that
and
we have also been given the trust by
political institutions for the second
time I have been invited to the G20
Summit to give a speech about the
importance of the sport
we have now different corporations for
example with the world health
organizations U.N women un um
different
organizations and they count on FIFA in
order to
realize something and we are very proud
of that
and we keep saying it with so much proud
these people they wouldn't sit in the
same room with FIFA if they didn't trust
FIFA but they trust us
and they see the results and they see
what we are doing and they know that
they can count on us
we also promised that we would review
the transfer system
how
how do you say this in Spanish transfer
yes is it the same the same thing
transfer well basically the transfer
matching system we said that we would
review this
[Music]
why because every time that a police
Force checks a transfer or the signing
of a player they used to find something
this wasn't right the payment was made
to this sort of that account we knew
that we had to solve that and we did so
on how
do we do it by the creation of the FIFA
Clearinghouse
a clearing house that
in the first instance we'll make sure
that all the solidarity payment
for the Youth and the young players will
go to the training clubs because
when
seven billion dollars are spent in a
single year in transfers and 700 million
dollars are paid in agent fees only 70
million dollars are invested in the
development of youth football this is
just not acceptable and that's why we
decided to act and this is only the
first step
obviously we also established and
implemented a new agent
Radiance regulation far more transparent
and clear
we have standardized
the rules for
players loans
and we have come up with rules and we
will keep on working on rules for
women's football in the past we had
nothing for instance on maternity leave
pregnancy what happens then so we are
now working on this and we will not stop
here
see
I promised you that we would revised the
international match calendar
the mic which is the most important
tools for all of you for all of us
indeed it's all about coordinating the
national team matches and the club
matches it's about releasing the players
for the national teams
it's about traveling
it's about going to the final
tournaments for the confederations going
to the World Cup and two days ago in
Kigali we read an agreement
for this new international match
calendar
until 2030. we'll have more visibility
more clarity for a couple of years so we
may now work on this
and be more inclusive than we will ever
be
I am now looking at the fifo president
David Alonso and I'll thank him
we must protect
the welfare and well-being of the
players
therefore we created a task force to
study how for each of these cases we
would protect the welfare so that they
will have a certain block period for
holidays that they would rest after the
matches
and we want everything to go smoothly
for everyone
and of course
I have to go back to English because
this is a typical English
part we have continued and we are
continuing to
evolve the laws of the game
together with ifap
we have been introducing VAR now in over
100 countries around the world
we will be introducing VAR light
to allow those who have less means
to have VAR but you still need around
four cameras to be able to do that and
we are working on
a last level so to say on a first level
if you want depending where you take the
ranking
or if I take a similarity with one of
our sponsors who has a light they also
have zero so we can call it var0 or VAR
or video support for those who don't
have
four cameras but less at least one
camera to have a small video help for
the referee we tested it in the Futsal
World Cup and it works and it works and
will continue to test it to give really
everyone of the 20011 Association the
possibility to have some technological
help for the referee because it is very
very difficult
to be a referee at every level of course
we are also testing because we always
want to
be striving for attacking football so we
are testing a new off-site rule to give
a bit more advantage to the attacker but
you know these are tests that we will
see what
what they will bring where in any case
always open to test whatever we we can
whatever we think makes football more
attractive for the fans who are watching
it on TV
oh
we have also when we talk about our
social responsibility
we improved our social responsibility we
promised to do so and we did that and we
did so many other things we created a
foundation by the former who's led by
the former president of Argentina
Maurizio Marcos thank you very much for
that
and the foundation
acts in so many parts of the world
we have created a football for school
program
where
students everywhere in the world
can not only play football
but they also learn how to live their
life through the rules of the game
foreign
we also work to protect miners with the
FIFA Guardian program
we work with the UN Odyssey
against the manipulation of the game
we work to protect the climate
with a cop in Glasgow
and we also
work to protect human rights everywhere
in the world but we will talk about this
specifically later on
in the end
what we promised you
is to keep on working to work a lot with
honesty
to work in order to protect football
to protect the member associations
to protect our fans
from all over the world
why because we always
need to remember our people especially
in our formal congresses such as this
one we always need to remember that
football is a synonym of joy happiness
peace
football
is a synonym of
unity and football unites the world
achieved
in the last
four years
now so that you cannot tell me that you
didn't know what would come up
I will tell you what will come up in the
next four years
my promises our promises for the next
four years
because there is a lot
to be looking forward to mainly of
course in the areas of competitions
and development
because we are here to organize
competitions
and to develop football
not to do other things organize
competitions and develop football mainly
without forgetting the rest
so when it comes
to competitions well the first point is
that we will of course deliver
the greatest
FIFA Women's World Cup ever in 2023 and
we will be boosting women's football
tremendously not only because we moved
from 24 to 32 teams but for many other
reasons it's also on this I will come
back a bit later
besides that and this is again for all
of you and for the fans we will of
course organize the greatest FIFA men's
World Cup ever
in 2026
also because we moved from 32 to 48
teams and from 64 to 104.
matches but
because this will be the most inclusive
World Cup
ever and we want to be and we have to be
inclusive
and of course you the Congress
will have the right and the duty to
decide on the hosts of future men's and
women's World Cup in the coming year
so it's a big
responsibility
for FIFA
for you for the world
we also decided to create a new club
World Cup
this new club World Cup will be played
every four years
from 2025 onwards
we'll have the best 32 teams of the
world
they will compete
in a said Stadium
to decide who will be crowned the best
club in the world indeed we need way
more and no less competitions at the
worldwide level we want football to
evolve to develop worldwide
and we are discussing similar ideas for
the Women's Club
about organizing A Woman's Club World
Cup we will discuss the format but we
should Implement A Woman's Club World
Cup
in addition each year
we will organize a small tournament with
all the winners of the Confederation
tournaments the winner of the tournament
will face the European wiener
the European winner in a stadium
somewhere in the world
it's a national team football
also
create occasions for teams from
different confederations to play each
other which is something that is quite
complex and difficult these days so
we discussed the creation of what we
call the FIFA World Series
in March every second year on the even
years before the World Cup and before
the Copa America European championship
when teams are free for friendly games
we will organize this FIFA World Series
for those teams who want four teams from
four different confederations who can
join and play together and encounter
each other to create communities from
all over the world
and as FIFA we have a duty as well to
assist and help all those who ask us for
it and so we are of course working with
some confederations with some Regional
associations
to uh discuss potential and how we can
help them to create new club
competitions national team competitions
at Regional at local level because uh
when I hear that there is too much
football
well maybe yes
but certainly not everywhere
actually in the majority of the world
there is not enough football not enough
quality football and when you see the
passion that exists for football
then you have to do something we
organized last year
the FIFA Arab cup as a test event for
the World Cup it was an incredible
incredible success for the Arab world
450 million people 23 countries
great success doesn't touch the top or
the elite of football but has a great
great impact only this year I was in
Iraq where I witnessed the opening game
of the Gulf
cup
an incredible incredible passion in Iraq
and incredible event I went then to
Thailand as well where I witnessed the
final of the Southeast Asian cup between
Thailand
and Vietnam
great celebration of football and it's
our duty and Our obligation to support
this kind of
events
let's talk about youth football
will have to make amends for the new
cycle indeed u17 World Cup
will now be played from 2025 each year
for boys and girls
so that we won't lose a generation each
generation will be entitled to compete
in a u-17 World Cup
we'll have way more team than ever
to this new World Cup
in terms of the u20 World Cup we will
increase the number of participating
teams for the women's edition
and we may organize a football festival
for the younger ones below 15 years of
age
and of course
we will also improve our regulations and
the FIFA statues
good governance principles who have
brought us this far we will protect them
and we will continue to involve them
we will continue to look at the transfer
system
to make sure
that
everything works well during the
transfers
and that is why
we will
maybe have a discussion
in order to improve the transparency of
the transfer fees and the salaries
and it might be necessary to introduce a
cap
and we have to think about how you can
calculate the caps everything is
possible today and we will have to look
at it with all the other stakeholders
and we will see what we can do
foreign
we will also
and it is obviously very clear when we
talk about transparency and development
we will continue in the development of
football
2.5 million dollars will be invested in
the next four years specifically they
will go specifically into the
development of football
and it will be controlled as well
we want to promote football development
and we have a very interesting project
that Arsenal will present later on this
project is the talent development scheme
the TDS this is a scheme for every
Talent all around the world to give them
a chance and to become a great player
it is not impossible
which is neat organization work and
that's what we are here for we are here
to help you all
and of course the same goes for referee
development and here we count on who
will talk about all these aspects
but what we can tell you is that we will
invest in Team One the referee's team
you've seen it in the
annual report in a financial report you
will hear it
after as well when you present the new
cycle
we are promising you
record revenues for the next Fourier
cycle of 11 billion US dollars
so from 6.4 which became 7.5 in the last
cycle we go to 11 billion US dollars
and actually the new club World Cup is
even not included in that so I think
this figure will increase still by at
least a couple of billions
we will see I count on our teams to make
that happen they know that they can
count on me as well to make it happen
because it is finally
for all of you
and obviously
we need to care about the fans
and the new generations and their
engagement and the promise I make here
is
that we will continue of course to
organize the best competitions ever
everywhere in the world
when we organize a small tournament here
in Rwanda it has to be the best
tournament so that everyone
can enjoy
but we'll develop as well our platform
FIFA Plus
FIFA plus who is becoming and will
become
also a source of revenue for many
associations
who will have their games
broadcasted all over the world
thanks to FIFA we democratize football
from every country to every country
and this is a commitment that we can
give you and also for the Young
Generation as well
and those who still believe that they
are young like all of us
e-football
e-football is part of football it's part
of the future
and be sure of one thing
the new FIFA
not the new FIFA institution but the new
FIFA game
the FIFA 25 26 27 28 and so on
will always be the best e-game and the
best experience for any young girl and
young boy who loves this gaming so we
are working on that and you will have
news on this
very very soon
and finally let me uh and for those who
count it it's 11 points so as it was 11
for the achievements there are many more
but we leave the substitutes for the
additional time when Pierre Luigi tells
us how many minutes we have left
the 11th point
is all obviously also
the corporate social responsibility
element of our job we are a football
organization
we are not
the Red Cross or Greenpeace or
any other organization who are doing
great work we are a football
organization we have to organize
competitions we have to develop football
but we have a responsibility as well
we have a responsibility to help tackle
Global challenges
and we will continue to do that whether
we speak about climate whether we speak
about human rights whether we speak
about diseases or disabilities
about anything
will play our part in the team in
respect of the fact that we are 211
countries
representing the entire world
so again
in conclusion and after thanking you for
listening to me and apologizing with
interpreters
for the many switches I would simply
like to uh
assure you of my continued commitment
with you as part of your team
and
to Simply ask you
to remember
that football is
Joy
happiness
passion
love
and peace
and that football is here to unite our
beautiful world thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]
unite the world
football is passion
and it belongs to all of us
oh a stunning efforts
who unites the world
[Music]
people will come to the Middle East to
learn about our culture
foreign
thanks to football
my country was brought together from the
division of hate and Civil War
to change the world
football unites Us in Hope
is
I remember 2019 the biggest stage of all
for the women's game and I remember the
goal it's truly aquam and it's a goal
for Germany
and what it meant to everybody back home
the moment we qualified
the emotions the happiness it was
incredible I remember the flags the
passion the fans
the power of the trophy the Euphoria the
emotion
celebration that's football
it's peace
us all
[Music]
[Applause]
for the next agenda item I have to hand
the floor to
my senior vice president
please the floor is yours
thank you Mr President
good morning everyone
team members of the council
the delegates of the FIFA member
associations dear friends
in accordance with article 33 paragraph
2 of the FIFA statutes
the FIFA president shall be elected by
the Congress for a period of four years
and the year following the FIFA World
Cup
the first term of office 2019 2023
of the incumbent FIFA president ends
after this Congress
accordingly the FIFA Congress will today
elect the FIFA president for the period
from 2023 to 2027.
the incumbent FIFA president Gianni
Infantino is the only candidate standing
for this election
article 30 paragraph 3 of the FIFA
statutes and the art an article 52
paragraph 3 of the FIFA governance
regulations provide that the Congress
may decide to elect the FIFA president
by acclamation where there is only one
candidate
of the delegates of this Congress are in
agreement we will now proceed to the
election of the incoming FIFA president
for the
2023-2027 term of office by acclamation
I'm now calling on the Congress
to give a round of applause to elect
Gianni Infantino as a FIFA president for
the period from 20 23 to 2027.
thank you
Mr Infantino is this elected the FIFA
president for a second term of office
for the period from 2023 to 2027.
congratulations Infantino
please it's your stage
thank you very much I I prefer to stay
seated so I don't risk to to fall down
um let me see play thank all of you
my family
my wife
my friends
my team
all of you
the FIFA team
the council team the committee's team
the member associations team
the Legends team
I would have loved to be a legend as
well
[Laughter]
all those who who love me
and I know there are so many
and those who hate me I know there are
few
[Music]
I love you all
of course today especially
we love you president
thank you
well being being of course president of
FIFA is an incredible incredible honor
it is an incredible incredible privilege
as well
and it is also a great great
responsibility
I'm truly humbled and Touched By by your
support
and I simply promise you that I will
continue
serving FIFA
serving football all over the world
serving all 211 member associations of
FIFA
leadership is obviously about listening
and learning
and you always learn and I think I'm
learning every day
and then leadership is also about acting
and
I'm certainly there
to act so you can continue
to trust on my commitment
and the only thing I'm asking you
is for this my second term
to continue
working hard
together
to unite the world with football thank
you very much thank you
where are we agenda item nine annual
reports
annual report activity is 9-1 in 2022 so
you have received
seconds
this which is the annual report of FIFA
with all the activities of the past year
and
I would like to launch a short video
that that gives us some
glimpse of what happened
[Music]
thank you
foreign
thank you for a nice video and I was
just told that and I have to apologize
we forgot something which is to mention
the latest newcomer in the FIFA Council
ednaldo Rodriguez Gomez from Brazil
who's sitting there
you can stand up he was elected
yesterday yesterday only
unanimously by commnable
Brazil the penta Campbell five times
world champion is the president is here
with us
thank you very much
thank you very much Mr President thank
you all for your trust
thank you president Infantino president
Alejandro and now members of the combo
thank you very much for the indication
and let's work in accordance with
International football for Brazil
football
a better place for all thank you very
much
and now speaking about the activities of
the past and of the future as well I
would like or I have the honor to ask a
professor
arson Wenger to join us
on the floor for his presentation
every town
everywhere
deserves a chance
to realize their goals
[Applause]
to reach their full potential
to play on the biggest stage of all
foreign
we believe the game is for everyone
wherever Talent exists it should have an
equal chance of flourishing that's why
we are proud to launch the talent
development scheme understanding how
every member Association can maximize
its potential ensuring Talent is
nurtured and developed
through knowledge exchange expertise
training education and funding the
talent development scheme will support
the creation of a robust pathway for
football's talents to thrive all playing
our part developing youth talent to
ensure it leads to senior success giving
every Talent everywhere a chance
good morning everybody
congratulations President for a very
convincing re-election and thank you as
well to support our program that I will
try to explain I must say when I was a
child I agreed it's a long long time ago
I was always disappointed when people
told me
football is not important get the real
job
I accept I accepted that the time the
fact that I was not completely normal
because football was my dream
and I must say today the situation has
changed
parents of children eight nine years old
stop me in the street and asked for
advice
to get their children to become
professional football players
I was put
groups like an Unstoppable Force
That Conquers every part of the world at
a huge pace
at the moment
where the whole world
lives at the same Pace gets the same
information at the same second
everybody raises football together we
had another example at the World Cup
the speed of that development
gives us a huge responsibility
but as well
a great opportunity that we want to take
now
we analyzed football and the state of
football in the world Guided by three
principles
allow
and give a chance of success to
everybody
give every Talent a chance and our third
principle was how can we help
we have created the talent development
scheme and as well I must say we have
FIFA has made a commitment
of an investment of 200 million dollars
on top of the forward program
you have to apply you have a window
opportunity until May and you have a
second one in October
and our Target is to create academies
the basic Target
is to create academies in every country
of the world and two have completed that
in 2026.
with us few principles that are for me
absolutely vital
it is you need to start young enough
and that means for me at 12 years
of age
12 years old girls and boys
we want to make a good player that means
to be identified
the identification of talent you can't
believe how many talents are lost in the
world because I have no opportunity but
the quality of the identification of
talent is absolutely vital receive
proper training
and good coaching we have on our
training center coaching online we
educate the coaches online and on site
and it is a good opportunity all over
the world for free to educate your
coaches
and another ingredient that is often
neglected is to put the best with the
best that is absolutely vital
to get great players they need to be
stimulated and that only happens when
the best play with the best
and for the counties where it is needed
we give support with coaches on the
ground we send coaches in paid by FIFA
that help you to develop your players
and educate your coaches
we have at the moment seven pilot
countries
we plan at the end of the year to have
more than 30 countries
and at the end of a cycle in 2026 we
plan at least to have 70 countries who
have coaches on the ground supported by
us and educated by us
oh
the reward of this
education will be visible
the president talked about that
is at the age of 17 years old I believe
personally that you equip a player with
the technical tools until the age of 17
at 17 years of age the competition
becomes important
therefore we have created
a World Cup for the under 17 every year
before we lost always a generation
because 16 years old couldn't get in a
17 year old team
and this means more opportunities for
you all I just would like to give you
two examples you have two talented
players at the age of 12 years old
at the age of 16
one has 500 hours practice and the other
one has thousand dollars practice
believe me there will be a difference
between the two players so that is
absolutely important that the number of
practices and of quality practices is
vital the second example is that you
take two plays of
a similar Talent at the age of 17 100
000 hours practice the other thousand
dollars practice one had the good coach
and won a bad coach we will be a
difference again you know that's why
this is absolutely vital to concentrate
on the quality of a coaching as well
one of the main targets of football and
of FIFA is to make football truly Global
I just would like to end by what I
believe is absolutely vital with only
one way to make football truly global
is to make education global
therefore you can count on our help and
with this program we have the
opportunity to do it let's do it
together thank you
[Applause]
thank you Arsen for uh
your really precious work
and your commitment and your program
which is incredible as I was saying we
invest and you are saying over 200
million for this program to give every
Talent a chance everywhere in the world
you will see the impact of this program
in the years to come so our son you will
be invited to come back to present the
results
of those winning titles following your
program
thank you so much
um
speaking about results and speaking
about performances another team
performed outstandingly at the last FIFA
World Cup it was a team one so the first
team that enters into the pitch the
first team that is actually qualified
for a World Cup
it's a team of the referees and they
perform at their highest level as well
so I would like to ask pierologicalina
to join us on stage whilst a video I
think is being played right
[Music]
I'm very proud
for all of you it is really
honor it was really a pleasure to be
here
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
good morning everybody and first of all
let me join arsening congratulating you
Johnny for your re-election
we are working together since a long
time I'm very very happy to be able to
continue to work for you in the future
indeed
2022 was
a very successful year for uh for
refereeing for FIFA referring we had two
Clover cup we had two Women's World Cup
under 17 and under 20.
we had Qatar 2022
where I would like to mention six match
officials made history by being selected
for the first time ever in this
competition we had six referees I would
not like to say six women referees but
they were women so we had six women
referees selected for this competition
with four of them
referring matches this was the first
time ever and I'm personally very proud
for what they did at the World Cup
um
success results
they do not come by chance you have seen
in the video what we have done to make
our match officials ready for the
competition and and FIFA as you know is
working hard and will continue to work
hard with each member Association to
improve the standard of refereeing
worldwide we are
as you can see from the next slide we
are working with you in
structuring the refereeing Department of
each member Association in
helping advising to organize the annual
activities of refereeing within the
member associations and also in
providing support in educating
directories
locally
as you can see we implemented
a schema
you can see from the next slide you can
you implemented the schema the so-called
teacher the teachers and we have the
annual
FIFA master
futuro courses to educate the FIFA
instructors we have the futuro 3 courses
to educate to prepare the regional FIFA
instructors and then we come to the
member association with the activity of
the FIFA instructors and the regional
instructors to educate the member
associations instructor instructors it
is a quite a big activity as you can see
from the next slide some numbers of what
we have done
supporting the member associations
in years where it was quite difficult
due to pandemic but we learn how to work
from remote and the number of activities
didn't decrease despite the
pandemic
in 2022 as well as in 2018 because of
the preparation of the World Cup the
last quarter of the year is dedicated
that was dedicated to the preparation of
the World Cup but for the 2020 through
three we have already planned with u
member Association
105 activities already in the period
January May and certainly the number
will be higher than last year last than
uh other next slide please and as you
know FIFA is a strong believer that
technology is important to support much
officials in their decision-making
process
um next you can see something about the
VAR you all know that you may do not
remember that the first match where VAR
was implemented was September 2016.
I still have some picture of the
president seated inside a small van
looking at monitors that was the first
first experience seven years later
every major competition in the world has
implemented the VAR and
51 member Association currently use VAR
in their top competition and 23 are in
the pipeline are in the in the route to
implement VAR soon
at the last World Cup we developed the
technology and we implemented the
so-called semi-automatic offsite
technology to support referees in taking
decisions about offside we had a
connected Bowl
sending datas 500 times per second we
had a
we are the system tracking position of
players 29 data points of each player
with the data center 50 seconds 50 times
per second
and you have seen on television as well
as on the screen at the stadium a new
three dimension graphic visualization to
give the possibility to see better
how the position of the player was
assessed thanks to the technology
this is our gold standard as the
president said
making football truly Global and making
you member Association
in a position to
implement technology
regardless the budget you have
regardless the size it's something that
we consider very very important so we
have already as you can see from the
next slide we have already
tested and ifub at the last annual
general meeting short ago approved the
so-called VAR light which is a sort of
silver level compared to the gold level
of VAR
it is something that reduces cost in the
region of 50 percent
but also reduces the
human resources needed and this is a
very good solution for those
competitions for those matches which are
covered by a number of cameras between
four and eight
but we want to go even
further with the so-called bronze level
the video support I know the president
likes the VAR zero
still to be decided but it's definitely
something that is even cheaper than the
VAR light
as you can see from from the next
there are
some
pros and cons the system works with
monitors at the pitch level
is cheaper it's definitely cheaper even
of the VAR light there are less human
resources needed and
[Music]
thank you
foreign
incident on the field of play are not
that much this is a solution this is a
technology ideal for competition for
matches covered by three or less cameras
so it's easy to understand that one or
two cameras are not in a position to
show everything going on on the field of
play but nevertheless if something very
important happens the referee can double
check on this Monitor and also we have
to be aware that the expectation from
this technology cannot be too high
and mainly cannot be compared to the VAR
or to the VAR light
2023 is the Real World Cup year and
125 days
are before the ball will start rolling
in Australia New Zealand we are working
hard our match officials are working
hard to be ready the day the ball will
start rolling there
video
you guys
[Applause]
for the excellent work you're doing with
team one and of course I'm sure that
they will be ready for uh the greatest
World Cup ever in Australia and New
Zealand
thank you very much another Applause for
the referees team one
we can move to the funny part of the
Congress which is the financials
the financial part
item
9.2 to 9.9
um
thinking to go into your direction I
propose that
we consolidate and merge agenda items
9.2 9.3 and 9.4 together and play a
video with an introductory address by
the FIFA finance committee chairman
Alejandro Dominguez the Consolidated
financial statement 22 when the FIFA
statutory financial statement 22 as well
as the original support as presented by
FIFA Chief finance officer Thomas payer
and the FIFA statutory auditor PWC
represented by Mr Patrick Falcon so we
can have a look at this video covering
three agenda items please
we are FIFA members and worldwide
football fans
first let us congratulate FIFA and the
FIFA president on their footballing
success achieved in the
2019-2022 cycle under the leadership of
president Mr Johnny Infantino
FIFA successfully hosted the first FIFA
World Cup in the Middle East and Arab
world
with packed stadium and a total of 172
goals
the FIFA World Cup 2022 in Qatar ignited
the world's love for football
I feel honored to have been in Doha
together with more than 1.4 million
football fans from all over the world to
witness the best FIFA World Cup ever
Qatar 2022 is also the most profitable
FIFA World Cup
in the
2019-2022 cycle FIFA Revenue reached a
new high of 7.6 billion dollars during
the
2019-2022 cycle
FIFA Chief records revenues and invested
more money back into football than ever
before
FIFA invested 5.3 billion dollars in
organizing FIFA's tournaments and
promoting Global football development
in addition FIFA invested 321 million
dollars through the FIFA covid-19 relief
plan to help the global football
Community mitigate the pandemic's impact
at the end of 2022
FIFA and Reserve had also reached an
unprecedented high of 4 billion dollars
45 percent higher than the amount at the
end of that
2015-2018 cycle
as chairman of the FIFA finance
committee I am very confident to report
here that FIFA's financial position is
healthy robust and sustainable with
sufficient cash and results for
worldwide football development in the
2023-2026 cycle in the
2023-2026 cycle budget FIFA will
increase forward 3.0 fund by a
significant 29 percent amounting to
2.25 billion dollars on top of it FIFA
will dedicate 660 million dollars to the
football Development Fund to support
FIFA's members Association and
Confederation in football development we
look ahead to 2023 a year with which
FIFA will organize the FIFA Women's
World Cup in Australia and New Zealand
let us work together to give the world
a fantastic FIFA Women's World Cup thank
you all
dear president dear members of the FIFA
Council the young Congress delegates
it's my honor today to present FIFA's
Consolidated financial statements for
2020.
[Music]
thank you
for the financial cycle in all key
financial parameters for the full cycle
Revenue amounts to 7 billion and 568
million US dollars above the full cycle
Revenue budget by 18 and setting called
despite the covid-19 pandemic
the largest jail come from the sale of
Television broadcasting rights
accounting for 45 percent of the full
cycle Revenue
followed by marketing rights at 24
percent
13 by hospitality and ticketing and by
licensing rights eight percent is from
other revenue and income
all five Revenue categories exceeded
their budget targets and all categories
set new record levels
Revenue in 2022
totaled 5 billion and 760 US dollars
another record figure that exceeded the
2018 amount by 24 percent
FIFA's expenses and Investments for the
full cycle amount
to 6 billion and 302 million US dollars
investments into football activities
reached a new record with almost 5.3
billion US dollars
this is 186 million US Dollars higher
than budgeted desire amount is thanks to
the new Talent Development scheme which
was
proved by the FIFA Council in December
of last year
for the year 2022 FIFA expenses among
billion and 404 million of which 59
percent was dedicated to organize and
Stage the FIFA World Cup Qatar and out
of FIFA events
investments in development and education
programs totaled 1 billion and 30 US
dollar including 605 million for 2.0
since the global pandemic delayed the
use of funds and FIFA's member
associations were unable to use the
entire young forward 2.0 entitlements
FIFA reserved all outstanding
entitlements for views
the net result for 2022 region and 368
million US Dollars offsetting the
structural negative results in the first
three years of the cycle
resulting in a net result of 1 billion
and
187 million at the end of the full cycle
17 to 2022 well above the boat
the balance sheet is at 31st December
2022 is a reflection of FIFA solid
financial situation at the end of the
cycle
FIFA's balance sheet continue to be
strong with total assets of 6 billion
196 million US dollars
of which percent were in the form of
cash cash equivalents and financial
assets
another key consideration in the balance
sheet is FIFA's Reserves which reached
the new high of 3 billion and 971
million dollars
45 percent higher than the level of the
previous cycle
in summary fifos balance sheet remains
exceptionally robust and builds a solid
Financial foundation for football
development in the future for 4 or 3.0
and the budget cycle
in addition to the Consolidated
Financial State the FIFA Administration
is also responsible for preparing FIFA
Standalone financial statements in
accordance with the Swiss law and FIFA
statutes please note that these
statements reflect FIFA's financial
situation alone Association FIFA
statutory accounts or previous Franks
the key financials include net result
for 2022 is 14 million Swiss Francs
the association capital and reserves
amount to 156 million Swiss Francs
reserves for statutory obligations
amount to 3 billion 505 million Swiss
Francs all financial information and
details are included in the 2022 annual
report that has been distributed to you
in advance
the FIFA counts still the governance
audit and compliance committee
maintenance committee have reviewed and
approved the Consolidated fundaments for
2022 and the statutory financial
statements for 2022 and recommend that
the FIFA Congress approved them
furthermore the FIFA financial
statements for 2022 have been by FIFA's
auditor it's my pleasure now to Mr
balcony from PWC
dear president the member of the council
the ladies and gentlemen
I'm pleased to present today the results
of our on behalf of
pricewaterhousecoopers limited
Switzerland as Thomas fire explained
before we audited two different sets of
financial statements on the one hand the
Consolidated financial statements and on
the other hand the statutory financial
statements of FIFA I would like with the
results of the audit of the FIFA's
consort financial statement
you will find our audit opinion on pages
294 to 300 in FIFA's annual report
on page 294 the following is explained
first of all overall materiality
secondly the audit score finally the two
key audit matters on the one hand the
appropriateness and application of the
revenue recognition policy and on the
other hand the financial implications
of the legal cases and or potential AIMS
in our opinion the Consolidated
financials give a true and Fair View of
the Consolidated financial position of
the group of its Consolidated financial
performance
and of its Consolidated cash flows in
accordance with the International
Financial standards IRS and comply with
this result
I have nothing to add to our conclusion
in addition I shortly present the
results of the audit of fever statutory
financial statements
we confirm that FIFA statutory Financial
State
are prepared in line with Swiss law and
of incorporation furthermore we confirm
that an internal control system exists
as required from the Swiss law
therefore we recommend that the
Consolidated financial statements and
the statutory Financial fever are
approved by the Congress thank you for
your attention and for your trust
thank you very much are there any
questions to Mr Dominguez to Mr or to Mr
balcony
this is not the case so we can move
directly to agenda item nine point five
reports from the FIFA governance audit
and compliance
we have a short video the chairman judge
mudgal please let's have a look at the
video
Mr President Madam Secretary General
members of the FIFA Council and
delegates to the Congress
it is my pleasure to show you the
achievements of FIFA in the year 2022
FIFA continued to uphold and enforce the
highest standards of governance and
compliance in all areas of its
operations despite the challenges posed
by the global pandemic FIFA was able to
initiate a series of projects that
resulted in grade six FIFA provided its
support to member associations with the
financial boost 1.5 billion US dollars
through grants and Loans while many
members of associations were facing
pandemic induced
tips the whole initiative is overseen by
covid-19 relief planned steering
committee at both member associations
and confrontation levels
I'm also pleased to announce that the
first world football remission fund
project was successfully launched in
2022 version of these funds and the
operation of the project are carefully
overseen by the word football remission
fund board and closely monitored by the
governance audit and compliance
Committee of FIFA
FIFA's commitment governance and
compliance is unwavering the governance
audit and compliance committee
continued its focus on key areas such as
human rights sustainability audit and
compliance
the audit and compliance working group
monitored the FIFA forward funds to
ensure debuts
the Review Committee and compensation
trap committee carried out their tasks
with transparency and impartiality
in FIFA's annual report there is a
dedicated section
the annual compensation paid to key
members of Senior Management the
chairpersons of the Committees and
members of the FIFA Council I am proud
to say
that FIFA was once again ranked in the
top tier of international in sporting
federations for its governing standard
following a review by the Association of
Summer Olympic federations in 2022
as we look ahead to 2023 FIFA remains
committed to transparency and
accountability in governance audit and
compliance
taking into consideration the lessons
learned
the 2022 World Cup in Qatar is
positioned for continued success in
these areas thank you
thank you very much judge
are there any questions for judgmental
who I can see here in front of me so
Dash
that's not the case so we can move to
agenda item 9.6
which is the vote on the approval of the
Consolidated financial statements for
and of the FIFA statutory financial
statements for 22 please
thank you
um let's proceed with the vote
on approval of the Consolidated
financial statement for 2022
and for the FIFA statutory financial
statement for 2022
press
if you approve no if you disagree an
abstention if you abstain and always
remember to submit your vote the vote is
starting now for 30 seconds
[Music]
thank you
then more seconds to go before the vote
is closed
please submit
and let's look at the result
foreign
this version was approved with by
203 member Association out of two and
seven
present and eligible to vote motion is
passed Mr President the floor is back to
you thank you so much
well done
so we can move to agenda item
9.7 which is the cycle budget for uh 20
to 26 the four-year cycle as well as a
detailed budget with 24. also here we
have a short video that we can show you
and I will show you the figures
people are all here as well
ladies ladies and gentlemen in
accordance with the FIFA statutes the
administration prepared the 23 to 26th
into 24 annual budget
the budget for the full cycle has been
prepared on the basis of the
international match calendar valid at
the time of the budget preparation in
early December 22
and with FIFA's strategic Vision making
football the revenue budget for the full
cycle is 11 billion US dollars
compared to the previous cycle it
represents an increase of 3.4 billion US
dollars or for 45 percent
the growth is primarily reflex in three
Revenue categories
the biggest growth in hospitality and
ticket sales
hospitality and ticket sales are
expected to reach 3.1 billion US dollars
this is an increase of more than 2
billion and distributed by the extension
from 32 to 48 team large capacity
stadiums in the USA Canada
and because FIFA will adopt a new
operating model for hospitality
whereby FIFA will sell the hospitality
packages directly to our fans worldwide
compared to selling the hospitality
rights to a dedicated
as in previous World Cups
the body broadcasting rights amount to
4.2 billion nearly 1 billion US dollar
higher than the level of the previous
cycle mainly due to the North American
time zones offering favorable coverage
across the globe for the FIFA World Cup
plus an expanded match schedule
end of 2022 43 of the budget for
television broadcasting rights had
already been contracted
sales from marketing rights are expected
to grow to 2.7 10 billion US dollars
of which 21 already been contracted by
the end of 2022. in budget for the 23 to
26 cycle has been established in line
with FIFA statutes to show a balanced
result
that is to have a result before taxes
and financial result in the amount of
100 million US dollars
the expenses and Investments are
budgeted at 10 million US dollars first
of all as you can see on the chart 89 of
the budget will be invested in football
activities which are therefore expected
to grow over proportion personally by 84
percent compared to the previous
and will reach a new high
expensive activities of growing with 15
well below the increase in Revenue as
you can see on the chart the main
increases come from development and
education and from competition and
events let me go into this details
FIFA continues to increase its
investment forward program
the new formal 3.0 program has a total
investment budget of 2 billion and 250
million US dollars
504 million more than direct Investments
tend to forward 2.0
on top of the increased FIFA forward
fund FIFA will dedicate 660 million US
dollars to a newly created football
Development Fund to support FIFA's
member associations and confederations
in football development
the FIFA World Cup 2026 will be another
little investment amounting to 3 billion
and 830 US dollars well over twice the
amount as for the FIFA World Cup in
Qatar
the FIFA World Cup 26 will be co-hosted
by Mexico Canada and the United States
of America
it will be the biggest
and the first edition of the FIFA World
Cup expanded to to 48 teams and across
16 host cities
the budget reflects this extension
which you can see in the prize money
preparation money and team services
all of this will have a direct to the
participating teams
opensus will increase as well in line
with the extension
furthermore the new operating model for
Hospitality will result in higher costs
as well
which however are more than compensated
with higher revenue from Hospitality
sales
the detailed budget for 2024 is based on
the ov3 to 26 for your budget
for 2024 the revenue budget amounts to
293 million mainly coming from non-fifa
World Cup tournaments
the total expense budget for 24 is 1
billion 189 million US dollars
of which 79 will be invested on football
and 21 on the administration
the result before taxes and financial
result is budgeted at the negative
997 million US dollars
the negative in the first three years of
the cycle will be cut by the FIFA World
Cup yield so we expect the positive net
result for the whole 23 to 26 cycle the
FIFA Council and the finance committee
have reviewed and approved of the
budgets for 2024 and photophosa
and recommend that the FIFA Congress
approved
thank you for your attention
thank you definitely an impressive
budget for the next four year cycle
that is not thicker then we can move to
agenda item 9.8 the vote on the approval
of the cycle budget
423-26 and the detailed budget for 24.
Pharma please yes president and
instruction
is to vote on approval
of the cycle budget for 20 23 6 and the
detailed budget for 2024
if you agree press yes if you disapprove
press no and if you abstain
please press abstention and always but
who is the submit button the evoting is
that now and you have 30 seconds to cast
your vote
[Music]
thank you
ten seconds left before the E 14 is
closed
electron watch is closed now
cut the result
Mr President very impressive
206 member Association out of 207
present and eligible to vote have
approved
upload
back to you
so now we have to deliver
now we have to deliver on
okay uh agenda item
9.9 the appointment of the Auditors 23
to 25 period according to Article 28
paragraph 2p of the FIFA statutes the
Congress is responsible for the
appointment of the Auditors and
according to article 62 of the visual
statutes the Auditors shall be appointed
for a period of three years
and date may be renewed
and the FIFA Council have reviewed the
proposals to reappoint uh
pricewaterhousecoopers are gay as FIFA
statutory auditor for the 23 to 25
period and recommend to the Congress to
approve this
so for the vote I hand over again to the
secretaries thank you president
instruction
raise as follow
delegates are invited to vote on
approval of the appointment of price
what house Cooper again as the FIFA for
the cycle 2023 25 three years
if you agree with the recommendation
press yes if you disapprove press no and
if you abstain press abstention and
always always remember to validate by
pressing the sub
the e-voting is starting now open for 30
seconds
[Music]
thank you
second left
to validate your vote
vote is closed under source
the results
here again president
the proposal to appoint
price water house Cooper eggy as a FIFA
auditor for Superior 2023
2020 five has been approved by almost
all the member Association here present
and eligible with 206 out of 207 vote
casts this also concludes Mr President
the voting process back to you
thank you very much so congratulations
to PWC for having been
invented as the Auditors of FIFA we can
move now gender item number 10
discussion of proposals duly submitted
by member associations and the council
within the period stipulated in Article
28 paragraph one of the FIFA statutes
uh so with regard to the agenda item
proposed or region Football Association
Michael Lamas president of the Gibraltar
Football Association and chair person of
the FIFA human rights and social
responsibility subcommittee
who can unfortunately not be here with
today has prepared or reply
to this particular request so we can
launch the video thank you
Dear Mr President
dear Madame Secretary General
friends from Member associations around
them
my name is Michael yamas I am president
of the Gibraltar Football Association
and member of the FIFA governance
Audits and compliance committee
honor to speak to you today in Mighty as
the chairperson of the subcommittee on
human rights and social responsibility
this subcommittee was formally
constituted in the FIFA governance
regulations but last year
and prior to that separated as a working
group since September 2021
our mandate is to advise the FIFA
Council on matters
relating to human rights
safeguarding and Child Protection
sustainability and environment
and to prepare regular reports for the
attention of the FIFA Council
the reason why the sub subcommittee was
recently formalized with institutional
structures of FIFA is in region of the
growing importance and public interest
in matters relating to human rights
and to further explore how FIFA and
football can have a positive impact
sphere
ladies and gentlemen I am sure you will
agree with me that these are topics that
ought to be at the core of who we are as
an organization and a global global
sport
we have all used the power of football
to change lives to build communities and
to bring about positive social change
and this is precisely what has been done
engaging competent and international
recognized bodies such as the
the BWI and others
but we equally know that as custodians
of the game we have a responsibility
to actively work to provide for an
environment in which football can
unleash this year in power
this means amongst
to promote a safe and inclusive
environment for players referees coaches
and everyone involved in the game
to ensure
everyone working in football is treated
with and respect
and to act really towards the planet we
all live in
over the past years our group has had
regular fruitful exchanges with members
of the FIFA Administration who are on
these topics
as power engagement we also paid a visit
to Doha last August
to obtain a first-hand impression of the
situation on the ground
and to consider the human rights and
environmental measures
in preparation of the FIFA World Cup
Qatar 22.
it was evident to all of us that
considerable effort had gone into
addressing these challenging topics in
the context of the World Cup
and we also observed firsthand
tournament has served as a catalyst for
what an important change in the country
for example we learned about the
measures taken to build energy efficient
stadiums and the efforts made to reduce
and compensate how's gas emissions
we learned about the second to ensure
the tournament is safe to attend for
everyone
including alignment between FIFA and the
host country on police interventions
and a far-reaching program to ensure the
event accessible for disabled fans
perhaps of most topical interests
we learned about the programs designed
to improve the situation for workers
involved in the construction of
infrastructure and delivery of services
for the cup which have also had a wider
impact on labor conditions in Qatar more
generally
for example
we learned from our discussions with the
head of the ILO office in Doha about
these wide in labor laws which have
resulted in over 350 000 migrant workers
being able to freely change jobs in the
past two years
and over 280 000 workers benefiting from
the introduction of the new minimum wage
in
the significant legislative process
related to workers rights in Qatar that
underpin these results have been
positively received by the working group
and constitute
real structural reform which we deserves
to be acknowledged as possible and
meaningful progress and are a true
Legacy of hosting the FIFA World Cup in
Qatar and an example for the region as a
whole
in our report following the visit we
noted that despite the clear and
positive which has been made there are
still some mixed views on whether
sufficient progress has been achieved in
Qatar as a result of the World Cup
there are also different opinions as to
the exact
responsibility of FIFA in this area
against this background it was evident
to us that a more comprehensive
assessment would need to be conducted
after the competition
in particular to assess what FIFA can
really be expected to achieve in a host
country across the whole range of Human
Rights and social responsibility factors
we do acknowledge that there are a
number of complex and challenging
questions questions here which deserve
further stuff
with this in mind
The Proposal from the Football
Federation to conduct a further
assessment including in particular an
examination of the question of Remedy
within the meaning of paragraph six of
FIFA's own human rights policy and The
Guiding principles would therefore fall
be met of our sub committee
we think there is a clear Synergy here
with the existing work of our
subcommittee and so we are committed to
undertake this work
including a legal assessment
to do it in a trust Manner and then to
produce a public report at the end of it
which will include an analysis of these
matters both in the context of the FIFA
World Cup in Qatar and with regard to
Future tournaments
in this report we will to build on
detailed information provided by the
FIFA Administration and we will also
consult with and involve external
experts
given the complexity of the questions
being
we will also assess accommodations on
how tournament Legacy funds can become
another piece in the wider efforts
around remedy in the context of the FIFA
World Cup in Qatar and potentially few
tournaments
in this respect are as supportive of the
reason statements of the FIFA president
in which he announced that this time
round the FIFA Legacy fund will take a
wider and more Global dimension
focusing on education projects in
developing countries and the creation of
a labor Excellence Hub in partnership
with the ILO
dear friends let us acknowledge that
these are complex and challenging topics
that we are addressing
at the same time there can be little
doubt that FIFA's work
on these areas has grown increasingly
robust over the years and there is also
little doubt that we are starting to
have real tangible impact perhaps in a
manner that few other or business
sectors can have and that
is the power of football
the FIFA subcommittee on human rights
and social
responsibility stands ready to advance
and support FIFA's work in this and to
help ensure that football continues to
use its power to make an important
contribution in the fields of Human
Rights and the environment
I thank you for your room and wish you
all a successful
well many thanks to Michael yamas for
his very comprehensive report
is there any question or comment
this is not space then we can move
already to agenda item 11.
the president's closing remarks and
whilst I walk over there I think there
is a little bit though that will be
shown to you
[Applause]
dream of them
but dreams don't work unless you do
[Music]
reach for Perfection
fighting that voice
[Music]
[Applause]
I've never giving up
[Music]
[Applause]
one more Sprint
one more goal
one more time
[Applause]
foreign
so that when my moment comes
I'll be ready
What a Beautiful video showing us
what this year is actually about for for
us this year for FIFA is
the year of women is a woman's
as a father of four daughters for
beautiful daughters I should add I know
very well how much attention we need to
give
to women in our lives
and FIFA is no different on that so like
that
the Women's World Cup New Zealand
be a celebration
celebration of football celebration of
women's football
a celebration of progress a celebration
of equality
A Feast for everyone and it will not be
by any other topic and today barking in
a historic Journey for women's football
and for equality
and this will lead us
to a path
to equal pay
this journey has uh these steps
step one and step two have already been
taken by the FIFA Council
step one being equal conditions and
services
for all men and women playing at a FIFA
World Cup
this will be a reality already
for the club in 2023 same conditions as
for the World Cup 22 will be for the
players and coaching staff in the
Women's World Cup 23.
entails a significant increase
in the total prize money envelope
23 World Cup
it will be over three times more than in
where I was already president
but it will be 10 times more than in
2000 before I became president of FIFA
small
so we move from
15 million in 2015 to 150 million
in 2023.
for the first time ever I
try to dedicate a specific portion of
this payment
which mainly has to go to football
development but a specific portion of
that should go of course
to the players
now comes step three the most difficult
the most complicated step the step that
will take
longer time
and this is backed by our new commercial
strategy
with uh
the implementation of
a dedicated
marketing concept
for the women's game and for the women's
in particular
our ambition would be of course
to be able to have
equality in payments for the 26 months
and 27 women's what
this is the objective that we set
to our sin
Thief are stepping up
with actions not just with words as you
have seen thanks to the decisions of the
Council of the increase already now in
23.
on
prize money not just words
but action
stepping up but unfortunately this is
not
the case
of everyone across the industry
broadcasters and sponsors dear friends
have to do more in this respect for FIFA
for the Confederation member
associations
for everyone because it decides
this is a bit more difficult
to act
FIFA is receiving between 10 and 100
times
inferior offers for the women's world
than for the men's World Cup
often public broadcasters and big
countries offer us 100 million or more
to broadcast the men's World Cup
they offer us one million or less
to broadcast the women's world
do you think that is normal
and at the same time these same public
broadcasters who are paid
by the taxpayers money
they criticize FIFA
with less the others
for not guaranteeing
equal pay to men and women
you pay a hundred times less whereby
your viewing figures are very similar
maybe 20 25 percent less for the women
and for the men not 100 times less 20
percent
bless will offer US 20 less offer us 50.
but not 100. percent less
because how can we do it otherwise and
that's why we need all
to be on the same side
on this
fight
for equality for real equality
FIFA will do its part we've started
already
others
to do the same
and the news I have for those
broadcasters or sponsors who don't
want to
offer similar amounts then for the men's
World Cup is simply well
going to sell
women's football and women's prizes
women deserve much much more than that
and we are here to fight for them and
with them now we need to fight together
to achieve that because
the strategy that we have and our
ambition vicious plan can mean in 26 and
27 we have equal payments for men and
for women whereby all the member
associations revenues are also protected
and that each Association
who participates in the men or the
Women's World Cup will receive then what
they receive now confident
that we can achieve that
we are confident that we can help the
players the men and the women by
guaranteeing them
clear conditions
we're confident that we can help the
member associations the participating
member associations by guaranteeing them
that they can have more news than today
be it for the men's or the women's
World Cup
and we start this journey now
and my commitment there is to continue
working very hard
with my four daughters and with all the
women and in this room and outside of
this room because we defend exact
principles
thank you very much
this was my closing speech and I go back
there with another video
[Applause]
the team it's about yourself being the
best version of and really focusing on
the strong qualities of yourself within
that team
it just helps build dreams for so many
young girls
again
[Applause]
I'm so excited for the FIFA Women's
World Cup to come to New Zealand and
Australia my daughter is so excited
we're from New Zealand but she's really
Keen to get over to Australia and see
some games so just the opportunity just
to see this with ours it's fantastic
the football Sport and it can take women
and girls anywhere
beautiful game can Inspire it can lead
and it can be full of enjoyment for
everyone
[Applause]
see your friends there supporting you
that's the most important encouragement
for all the players to see your fans are
there with you to be there and witness
this amazing moment
movies
foreign
[Applause]
for me both World Cups were Sensational
over 120
000 fans that you have that's like we
have it for the rest of your life and
they shape you
[Applause]
I think it'll be a fantastic tournament
I think it'll break records just as the
Euros did and I think the it'll help the
women's game to continue to go from
strength to strength
when the women come to town for 30 days
whatever whatever country the World Cup
is hosted at the women they arrive in
cities around the world and
people take notice
the Women's World Cup is the single
biggest women's sporting event on the
pla bigger than it's ever been before
and it is now being shared across two
confederations for the first time and
the first time in the southern
hemisphere so what an outstanding
opportunity for this part of the world
or the Australian part of the world a
New Zealand part of the world to put on
the global stage visitors in
internationally but more importantly to
give the young and young boys of both
countries the chance to see the best
players in the world on the paddock
having to crack at each other for that
beautiful trophy
it's just amazing to see and
I'm super excited I can't express enough
that this is going to be the biggest and
best one
[Applause]
thank you very much we arrive soon at
the conclusion agenda item 12 is the
next Congress but before I would just
like you to have another quick look do
we have it because it was not planned
we have it to the best goal of the year
[Music]
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen marching olesky is
here can I come on stage
can you come on stage
so since since this was not planned we
didn't have any gift I just took my
jersey because he deserves much more
than that today this afternoon there is
uh an event of amputee football here in
Kigali
it's at 3 P.M right and also women's
we have to support that guys we have to
support it all of us so please help them
they are a great source of inspiration
for all of us thank you Martin's from
Poland
okay thank you thank you
okay
okay so
um agenda item 12 then
next Congress
uh will be on the 17th of May 2024
location to be confirmed in the meantime
time you will have a lunch which you
served up here right up here I
understand and the staff will guide
through the Congress Hall
okay to the lunch and for those who are
still here tonight pass by the Marriott
and we will have a little celebration
dinner
hopefully
thank you very much for coming
third FIFA Congress is closed freedom
thank you bye-bye
football unites the world
[Music]
Ripper
five Real Madrid Champions once again
[Music]
after the next half an hour or so here
to take your questions translations on
your headsets channel one for English
two for French three for Spanish and
four for German with that I will hand
over to the newly re-elected FIFA
president for some opening remarks
Johnny
thank you thank you very much Brian
hello everyone welcome to everyone and
it's a pleasure to have you all here
now I'd like to
start with uh
with some remarks
you remember before the start of the
World Cup in Doha
I felt I have to defend the World Cup
today after having been re-elected I
feel I have to defend FIFA
and I have a few questions as well for
you I because there are a few things
which
I really don't understand
and unfortunately because of a few of
you
all of you have to listen to another
monologue by Johnny Infantino I hope it
will be shorter than
the Doha monologue
but I want to say a couple of things I
don't understand for example
why some of you are so mean
why
why I
I don't get it
we work hard I work hard the whole FIFA
Team works hard
we don't steal we don't profit
maybe I don't speak so much to the media
but that's how I am and anyway it's much
better you write about football and not
football administrators That's My
Philosophy at least
maybe we don't leak anymore
secret information or what have you to
the media I don't know and that's why we
need to be criticized
but but we feel it's right
way to do
we intervene we speak I speak when there
is something to say when we do something
when we propose something
but for the rest we have to let football
to their protagonists FIFA president is
not
a protagonist of football it's the
players it's the coaches
it's those who have
fans all over the world
and we are part of those who have to
protect
defense
and the other thing I don't understand
and I'm asking you why whenever
some of you
write about FIFA or speak about FIFA
you say that it's only about money
that FIFA is rich
that when we propose a new competition
it's just a money-making exercise
and I can tell you that FIFA's about
football
and not about money
we need the money
obviously we need the money
to make football grow and live all over
the world
but I want to give you just an example
for that because
it's a bit tiring
it is a bit tiring
the Premier League the English Premier
League which is the most successful
competition in the world I think we all
agree
and I congratulate them for that
generates in one year
what FIFA generates in four years
okay in one year
the Premier League generates will be
generated in four years so the Premier
League is four times richer than FIFA
but there is one or two substantial
differences
the first one
is that the 20 24 25 billion that the
Premier League generates in four years
are distributed essentially
to 20 English clubs
and a little bit to some solidarity
projects
but the big part of 24 billion in four
years goes to 20 clubs in England
again congratulations well done
I praise them
when FIFA does one quarter of that 7
billion
this money doesn't go to 20 English
clubs or 20 German clubs or 20 Swiss
clubs
this money goes to 211 countries all
over the world
from Ethiopia to Nepal to Bolivia
to wherever you want 211 countries all
over the world
that's why we need the money and today
compared to the Past
everything is clear every dollar is
accounted for you can look at our annual
reports
everything is accounted for in the past
the 250 000 of the federations were
receiving only 10 percent of them were
audited
and maybe even not today 100 is audited
by external auditors
and when you speak about new
competitions
or about new formats again ah this is
FIFA it's always odd the calendar is
already full and it's adding and adding
and adding
what are we adding we were the only
organization in the world
who during covet
has suppressed a competition the
confederations cup or the new club World
Cup whichever you prefer in 21 did not
take place
everyone else has played their own
competitions until the end in one way or
another
we suppressed one because we're in a
very good thanks God and thanks for the
work stable
situation
but to come back to the Premier League
example
in order to generate its 7 billion a
year
the Premier League clubs
played 380 matches right
a year
380 each single Club
plays 38 in the Premier League plus
carabao cup plus FA cup plus replace 50
games a year more or less
50 games every year
when we add
a new competition
a new club World Cup
this corresponds
to
50 games 60 games
it's 10 games 15 games a year
it's one game per year
for each Club
one game per year
the World Cup
that we have
on average each country that
participates because those who don't
participate they don't play
so Egypt with Muhammad Salah didn't
participate they didn't play
but the other countries they play four
games on average in the World Cup the
winner seven now eight
four games on average means one game per
year
per country with which we Finance Global
football I don't know tell me why why
when the Italian League decides that
from now on a new super cup is played
with four teams in Saudi Arabia
fantastic I congratulate them the
Spanish do the same great more revenues
for Italian football for Spanish
football perfect
why nobody reacts
this is these are more games for the
same teams who play already many games
whereas we want to bring games to teams
who do not play sufficient games
and that's why I don't understand
why there is always this
Rich FIFA uh attack coming all the time
somebody was telling me that FIFA are or
is the Robin Hood of football
well maybe a little bit but with the
difference that we are not stealing from
the rich to give to the poor
we are commercializing and we give to
the rich as well but we give to the poor
also to make them grow
a little bit
in addition to that come the uh the
personal attacks because you attack FIFA
you attack the FIFA president in order
to attack
FIFA
again
why
give you one example in the press
conference in Doha
before the start of the World Cup
I said at some stage that I knew
how it felt to be discriminated because
I'm son of immigrants
and because I saw with my eyes what
happened in the borders
passports medical checks accumulation
and so on
but some of you instead of reporting
this they prefer to say that
I know what is discrimination because
I'm red I've red hairs and freckles
which is something I said
on Paso and go and listen again
to this interview
to see what I said
I don't need to like me
you don't need to love me
you can criticize me
of course and there are opinion articles
for that but please please please
remain
a bit
factual
why for example
some of you always give space
to people
who just for the sake of having free
publicity
criticize
FIFA or the FIFA president
some of these people were convicted
in the past by many things
I think
we have been working hard to show that
FIFA's
on track
and again I don't understand this
animosity because this goes in as well
with these critics which comes up every
now and then of some sort of corruption
and when we speak about corruption
that's always a very serious allegation
right
and when the Department of Justice of
the United States of America decides
to give back to the new FIFA over 200
million US dollars
I guess they probably check what they do
before they do it
because normally Swiss organizations or
others in Europe they tend to pay
and not Millions but billions of dollars
to the Department of Justice
so
why is this not highlighted that's my
feeling Maybe I'm Wrong
but I have this feeling and that's why I
need to say it
we spent I spent my life working hard
to get where I am
with all my team we're sitting here
which I'm proud of
today
I was re-elected
after having received more than 200
letters of endorsement I was really like
to understanding ovation
so an overwhelming majority has the
feeling
that I'm doing a pretty good job
including in Europe
but yet when I read articles well I
don't read them but I'm told
you shouldn't tell me what they write
you see
when I read articles
the best I can I can read as well he has
some support by some poor countries in
some poor continents with the names of
some countries so besides being racist
this kind of remarks
they are factually wrong
and I think a journalist has a duty to
be impartial
and correct
because the readers believe what they
read
and again most of you I'm sure are doing
that
so 200 more countries believe
we've done a good job
in the last four years
and before
and the same 200 plus countries
belief that we will do a good job as
well in the next four years based on the
plans that were presented and that were
approved unanimously
at the FIFA Council after discussing it
with all the stakeholders
and again
today or this year we will have the
women's
World Cup
we were discussing this recently
internally and
and this Women's World Cup should be a
celebration of women's football
to be
and yet it's more
some of the negativity which comes
always out so why is that why can we not
try
a little bit to focus
on some of the positive messages
we are here in Rwanda we're here in
Africa
in a place which is very inspirational
and
we want to focus on what is positive and
I think with what I said at the end
about the increased prize money about
the objective of going to equal pay and
unfortunately I have the bad habit as
most of you know
to do what I say so we will have to get
there but we'll have to discuss it
before with everyone
this should deserve I believe some
positive
feedback because these are
concrete concrete
facts
I think I'm going to stop here and I'll
let you ask questions it was not so long
thank you for having listened to me
thank you very much Gianni
thank you very much for just moving in
future
um okay if we could have some hands
raised please
um to take some of your questions again
the translations provided on channels
one two four
um one of our colleagues will bring the
microphones across if we go please to
Front Row
um near the right please
front rowing of their rights lady near
the right yes
thank you
congratulations Mr President
my name is Anita mugawa I'm a sports
journalist at the radio division here in
Rwanda
you my question you say that you love
African football what uh your hopes for
African football in next to five in next
five years to 10 years thank you so very
much
thank you for the question yes I I love
African football
um I love football generally but I
really feel that in Africa there is an
incredible talent and our sandwanger's
talent development scheme that he
presented today
will focus
on those countries who don't have the
possibilities like the bigger countries
maybe in Europe or north of South
America to give more talents more
chances
so by giving more talents more chances
and by increasing the participation of
African teams we almost double or we
basically double the participation of
African teams for men's and women's
World Cups
in in
26 and 23 for the women
we believe and I believe that we will
soon have some very good results at the
top level they use competitions being
played every year will also help in this
direction because what happens today for
example in Africa is that the teams
whereas in Europe the European
Championship is played every year at
Youth Level under 17.
in Africa because the World Cup is only
every two years
the associations they tend to train the
players only shortly before they have
the qualification for the World Cup and
if they are out they don't train anymore
until two years later and you lose a
whole generation so
this with the four-hour program
investment in Africa of around half a
billion in the next four years will
definitely have an impact for African
football and we had already Morocco in
the semi-final of the last World Cup so
let's see when Africa will be world
champion
thank you for your question we'll go to
the side now and uh from Rogan front
left please
Marca
are you worried about the tension the
tense environment at a national team
level rather than collab level and the
facts that some collapse doubt about
your
system or methodology
yes obviously as FIFA President we pay
pay very close attention to everything
that takes place
uh National Team level or Club
competitions
whenever we're here negative criticism
obviously
that's worrying for us
the club especially the big clubs
contribute a lot towards the development
of football not just in their own city
or country but worldwide
therefore we
wounds
for everything to go well then at the
end of the day we're all human beings we
can all make mistakes
that will be analyzed for instance in
Spain we know what happened
and we need to
see what kind of solution we can find
with sin crisis in many different
countries also in Italy
there are some clubs involved this is
not positive for football and I
[Music]
believe that we should all try to
provide a positive boost
for the football worldwide
I think that instead of
this animosity we need to try and find
Solutions
over here third row please
thank you
my question is uh
what should we African or football and
Rwanda in particular expect as you begin
your new term as FIFA president
and what do you think about having more
representatives in the World Cup for
Africa thank you so much
yes thank you we we have already taken
this decision and we moved from five to
nine and a half representatives from
Africa in the World Cup as of 2026
um
for the women's game as well we
increased the participation and for use
competitions which is also very
important we are going to double the
number of teams including number of
African teams obviously for the boys and
we are going to increase the number of
women's teams as well so
more inclusivity more participation
I think that's what the world needs
thank you
second row Tariq on the right
on the Women's World Cup actually
um
we announced that the prize money today
just from a technical point is that 110
million in prize money 40 million in
preparation that is at 150 and also do
you anticipate all of that money going
to the players that are playing in the
tournament or would you like to see that
money go into the game and on the same
topic on the Women's World Cup there's
been a lot of
um controversy the Australians and the
new zealanders have commented publicly
about this Saudi Arabian mooted Saudi
Arabian tourism sponsorship they don't
want it you might say nothing is signed
Etc but something is up even in the last
few days they seem to be quite upset do
you want to clarify what's happened with
that Saudi Arabian sponsorship thank you
very much
thank you very much so the the prize
money itself will be at 110 and then
there is an amount for the preparation
money uh the cost and so on and there is
amount for the uh
uh club uh program the production Club
program exactly so 110 and then I don't
remember
30 and 10 or something like this 31 and
11. it's 152 the precise number but you
will get it
from uh from our team
what we want to do as well
but we have not decided that we have
just been discussing it internally is to
allocate a part of it one part of it to
the players
and one part of it to the Federation for
investment in news football boys and
girls right
so all this will be elaborated in next
few weeks we'll be discussed internally
and we'll be then part of uh of
Regulation but I feel we feel that when
we speak about maybe prize money we have
to change if you since you are a great
English speaker maybe you can give us a
better name because prize money could be
a bit misleading right because a part of
that has to go to the players
that could be the prize money so to say
for the participant players but another
part as well
is obviously there to develop football
in in that country as well so we need to
divide that
on the visit Saudi question well
thanks for the question I can clarify
that that of course there were
discussions with uh with visit Saudi and
so on at the end uh
this discussion didn't lead into a
contract
um so
there was uh how do you say uh
a storm in a water glass do you say that
in English
you say in a water glass you see in
English
because uh you're more sophisticated in
England
but having said that having said that
let me say one more thing
FIFA is an organization of 211
countries
I said it in my speech I think as well
for us they are all the same
they're all the same
there wouldn't be anything bad and there
is anything bad in making sponsorships
from Saudi Arabia from China from the
United States of America from Brazil or
from India
as far as we are concerned in addition
to that FIFA is a global organization
now I understand when it comes for
example to Australia that Australia has
trade
with uh Saudi Arabia of I don't know one
and a half billion a year
between Australia and Saudi Arabia this
doesn't seem to be a problem or an issue
um
between Australian companies and Saudi
companies between a global organization
like FIFA and the Saudi
organization like visit Saudi this would
have been an issue there is something I
don't understand there is a double
standard here which I really don't
understand but there is no issue there
is no issue there is no contract there
are discussions and of course we want to
see how we can
involve Saudi sponsors in women's
football generally how we can involve
Sally sponsors in men football how we
can involve Qatari sponsors in women's
football and men's football
and all other sponsors from all over the
world
thanks Derek just behind Tariq on the
right still thank you
week after week we see how venices
is receiving insults in Spain
racist insults and we
see that nothing's happening with those
who are attacking venices what's
happening with this war what else can
FIFA do
as regards This
Racist issue for instance
disqualification from competitions
Etc what could FIFA do about this
well thank you very much for the
question first of all I would like to
show my greatest solidarity towards
businesses and all of those players who
are victims of racist attacks
it is evident that
with a
solidarity system that we have in
football every provider is responsible
of all the incidents that take place in
their competitions having said this
in FIFA and we did so during the World
Cup
we
have the disposal of the players if they
ask for it
a
monitoring mechanism of the social of
social media in order to get rid of
those negative narrative and insults it
worked very well during the World Cup
and it's a
key step as regards what happened on the
page on the page there's something that
we implemented in the FIFA competitions
that referees have to
not only the possibility but the
obligation to stop the games if there
are racist
attacks there is a three-step process
you stop the match
you announce it
that's the first step secondly
the players leave the page and
the speaker announces that if the
attacks continue the match will be
suspended
much
restarts and then if the attacks
continue
the match will stop and the three points
will go to the opponent
so these are the rules that should be
implemented in every single country
sometimes
it's easier said than done and the
theories easier than the practice but I
think that what we should work harder on
is education education and education
thank you
thank you go back to the front row
to you thank you
hello my name is Eric from Nairobi Kenya
a couple of days ago or the day before
yesterday you announced that the World
Cup will be expanded obviously to 14 40
teams but I've seen reports and articles
around the world that we may have boring
games feature initials like North
Macedonia Malin Africa Jamaica Iraq what
do you make of those those comments on
those reports
not much
[Laughter]
I believe that we'll have a great great
world cup I hope that Italy qualifies
for once again in a World Cup which is
not such a bad team and didn't qualify
with 32 so maybe with 48 Italy will
qualify
um otherwise we move to 64 or 128 until
Italy goes in but you know the quality
of the players today is is really really
growing at many levels
many top players Muhammad Salah with
Egypt didn't make it to the World Cup
um
the Italian national team did make it
Sweden with Ibrahimovic did make it some
turkey has always a good team they
didn't make it so there are good teams
Chile South American Good Team Colombia
top players everywhere in the biggest
leagues didn't make it
so we have I think Algeria with mares
didn't make it
so there are some very good teams I
think all over the world which have the
quality to uh to play in in a world cup
and to perform very well we've seen it
at this particular World Cup as well
where Japan
has been beating Germany and so on and
so forth so
we see some some surprise results which
are not so surprising because the
quality of the play is very high so
I'm sure that more teams means more
celebration and more quality as well
okay uh second row Matt blue shirt
thanks uh Matt Slater from the athletic
uh I've got an answer and a question you
asked a question
um the criticism I can't speak for
everyone here but the criticism I gave
for your speech in Doha was not about
your gag on red hair it was about the
implicit and explicit criticism you made
of dozens of people in that room
of the reporting that they had done over
a decade on qatar's labor rights rules
you said we were racist
now ironically that's the word that the
UN special repertoire used or uses about
the labor rights situation in Qatar
so that is what upset me and a great
many people
that I spoke to that day they were
deeply offended that you called us a
racist
so that's my answer
now I'd just like to ask a question then
I'd love to hear your response
would you clarify just so I don't
misunderstand you again
what you meant by your comparison to
your electoral campaign in 2016
and rwanda's recovery from genocide you
appear to make a direct comparison
between your
try try try again Spirit
amarander's recovery from that appalling
incident
well on the first thing I think I called
racists those who were qualifying fans
who had a different skin color
and were cheering for uh European teams
as not real fans that's when I used the
word racist
and I stick to that because a fan of
England a fan of Germany a fan of any
team can be from anywhere in the world
on your question
I find it really
incredible
that you can interpret what I say as
making an association with one of the
most terrible terrible tragedies that
happened in humanity in this country
with anything that happened in my life
anything
I don't know have you been to the
memorial
go to the memorial go to the memorial go
to the memorial it's very inspiring it's
inspiring for everyone I brought my
children to the memorial
I understand it's your job
I understand it's your job and I respect
your job so much believe me I respect it
so much but I would never make a
comparison with a tragedy between a
tragedy and between my life
what they want to say is that this
country is so inspiring sorry I speak it
is so inspiring for so many people on
what has been done
that when we come with our little
problems
sometimes
you know we should
we should just you know be a bit more
humble about things that's all that I
said
that's all that I said
hey you can shake head
doesn't change
okay thanks Matt
question over on the right lady in the
black and white
be on the camera just be on the camera
yes
conversations Mr President I'm called
graceline zimbabazi from Uganda and I
work for NBA support you talked about uh
the focus for the four times the four
years is the women football and he talks
about equality and equal pay but there
is a
and actually representation of women
especially when it comes to the
technical aspect Administration and as
well as
you know
let's say on your committee how willing
are you to see that changes
yes thank you very much for the question
I think this is another area where this
country can give lessons to the world
and to FIFA as well where you have more
women in the parliament more women
ministers if I understand well as well
and of course we have much more to do in
in that area we tried also there to
improve a little bit we have six women
in the FIFA Council we have a woman
Secretary General of FIFA we have a
couple of women in the management Board
of FIFA
but football is still very much of a of
a man's sport and I think and I hope and
I believe that boosting and developing
women's football will help to go in that
direction